l'an prochain il pourra voir une hausse
des tarifs de 4 5% alors on va faire une
modification à la loi pour mieux écrire
un plafond système est fragile
tempête puis il y en a plus de cours à
brno d'eux mêmes
ça a été et madame brochu le dit sur le
terrain quand j'étais là la chute
pendant bauchoux bonsoir ne pas
ça a été la trempette qui vous a pas
coûté plus cher parce que le verglas
c'est toutes les lignes de transmission
mais en termes de rebranchement ça a été
l'épisode le plus difficile dit drôle et
absolument absolument depuis depuis
cette période là et c'était c'était une
tempête d'une rare violence puis c'était
pas ne s'était pas des vins qui ont fait
tomber des branches sur le réseau de
distribution ce sont des arbres qui ont
été arrachés et
qu'ils ont tombé sur sur les films et
pas un pas deux je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez du jeu que planck quand on
était petit mais il y avait des creux
planque d'arbres partout partout sur les
fils sont les maisons des poteaux cassés
des transformateurs qui coulait à terre
dans un espace
trés
trés feillu forêt et vous avez chiffré
est ce que ça vous occupe chez comme
facture 70 millions oui c'est ces
finales où ça va il va peut-être
accumuler encore là mais je vous dirais
qu'on est dans les ordres de grandeur de
70 millions la dernière tempête qu'on
avait eue et datait de l'halloween 2019
elle est assez localisé dans le bout de
la valse avait coûté 30 millions il y
avait un million de clients qui ont
marqué les tristes et pendant le temps
ça avait coûté 30 millions l'oeil un
demi million de clients qui ont manqué
l'électricité mais l'ampleur des travaux
à accomplir avec aucune commune mesure
bon alors avec les changements
climatiques comment on s'adapte quelles
leçons vous tirer de ça comment on peut
solidifier ce réseau en fait on
personnellement et comparativement tire
plusieurs leçons c'est certain que dans
les dix dernières années hydro-québec
sous-investis un contrôle de la
végétation pour toutes sortes de bonnes
ou mauvaises raisons alors on accélère
sur beaucoup depuis deux ans on investit
100 millions par année pour aller
travailler ce qu'on appelle l'élagage
des arbres j'en profite pour dire aux
gens des fois non à la guerre arrive
qu'ils sont pas contents parce qu'on
coupe des branches d'arbres qui sont
projetés mais il faut faire une coupe au
carré d'une fois
maintenant il ya une loi qui existaient
puis qui s'appelle la loi sur les arbres
et qui nous empêchait dans le passé de
couper un arbre qui n'est qui menaçait
de tomber sur le nez mais qu'il n'avait
pas encore fait alors il fallait parler
que propriétaire c'est le propriétaire
nous dit non tu coupes pas même si là où
et quand marché puisqu'elle va tomber
sur l'aller on n'est pas loin là on aura
le droit de le faire bon alors ça ça va
nous aider il faut mettez-vous des
bouchées doubles j'avais suggéré 100
millions par année 100 millions par
rapport à 50 ou 60 doubler le budget de
la gare de l'agha juste un premier point
le deuxième point c'est que
je pense qu'on a somme toute assez bien
fait dans la dernière tempête en termes
de coordination avec le terrain avec les
services municipaux le style est
perfectible on va le faire notamment
dans des circonstances comme celles là
où on avait de la difficulté à atteindre
les zones de travaux parce que les
routes étaient bouchés meilleure
coordination
est ce qu'on va faire la prochaine fois
qu'on aura une panne dont importante en
proportion de cette panne n'avait pas
d'importance et qu'on va établir un
point du temps du jour on voit tout et
journée par exemple un rongeur en
conférence de presse dix minutes pour
que tout le monde l information en même
temps je pense que ça vaut son appli est
par ailleurs gg réaliser jusqu'à quel
point moi je le vis je vis à la campagne
il n'y a pas d'électricité pas d'eau
n'est pas d'installations sanitaires et
c'est de voir que dans ces points-là du
monde je pense que la société civile qui
a déjà fait beaucoup doit s'adapter
encore mieux pour avoir des lieux où il
ya une génératrice où il ya des douches
où les gens peuvent aller chercher l'eau
parce qu'il ya quand même des
communautés qui ont été mal pris donc
les municipalités la sécurité civile
d'avoir des lieux d'accès rapide pour
dépanner les gens puis comme vous dites
quand les toilettes marche peu plus le
robinet marche annoncée non mais ça crée
un niveau d'anxiété faux et l'autre afin
que les gens dans ce coin ici du monde
au moins réaliser c'est quand même temps
qu'on gérait cet épisode là en gérait
aussi de gatineau gatineau qui en même
temps avaient reçu de grands couteaux
les crues printanières menaçait de
d'inondation la région de gatineau à
faut savoir que quand quand l'hiver se
termine hydro-québec à vider ses
réservoirs justement pour être capable
d'accueillir la fonte des neiges l'at-on
aux bd sont au printemps quand on est
arrivés ou à aux mêmes heures que les
heures de tempête en deux jours il est
tombé autant d'eau qu'en deux mois les
réservoirs s'était rempli et donc on
gère et je vous dirai à l'air l'amener
des os qu'on laissait aller l'idée étant
de ne pas dépasser des limites pour pour
amener des ouvrages en rupture mais en
même temps pour ne pas et nos délais
gens en aval on est dans le même sujet
des changements climatiques des fortes
pluies non je vais vous parler de la
chaleur et aux états unis par exemple
est ce que ça change
le type d'électricité qu'on va exporter
au sud il va faire encore plus chaud aux
états unis ici aussi comment ça change
le portrait du comment vous adaptez mais
en fait c'est certain que la demande en
climatisation va aller en augmentant
on se croise je pense qu'il faut y
croire alors on va avoir des coups de
chaleur de plus en plus importants
falloir adapter les villes cessé d'avoir
des îlots de chaleur va falloir qu'on
change beaucoup nos modes d'adaptation
et tout pour les tristes et
d'hydro-québec par exemple le contrat
new york c'est de ne pas de ne pas
offrir ce qu'on ne peut pas offrir dans
les périodes de pointe l'été hydro
québec ont vraiment des capacités pour
permettre à des villes comme new york
permettent à montréal de ce climatisé de
manière raisonnable ce que non parce
qu'on ne fait pas par exemple contre new
york c'est de garantir de la puissance
en hiver parce que l'hiver on a besoin
du bt on peut être long lité et les
théâtres au web ce que ça mène aussi je
reviens au vin le chemin petit crochet
par le vin les poteaux l'enfouissement à
chaque fois on pose la question je pense
que j'ai entendu dire c'est de la folie
ça coûte trop cher est ce que vraiment
c'est de la folie ce qu'on peut en faire
quand même un peu puis les poteaux de
bronze qui peuvent être remplacés par
des poteaux de métal ou deux si non
alors surtout très bonne question de
l'enfouissement ça peut se faire de
l'enfouissement de réseaux de manière
parcimonieuse et ça coûte très cher le
réseau d'hydro-québec là toutes nos fils
l'inscription et où il fait six fois le
tour de la terre
c'est 100 milliards
cook on dit ça on dit il ya peut-être
des ondes qui sont plus fragiles et
l'oeil a peut-être d'autres façons de
créer de la résilience avec par exemple
les nouvelles batteries de grande
puissance pendant un certain temps qu'on
a pris 2 you tell it is king vous avez
peut-être un petit batteries chez vous
les parloirs de tesla ce sont des trucs
qui sont plus à échelle résidentiel ou
commercial
nous on développe des batteries de
résilience dans une communauté par
exemple à mégantic quand on ne
reconstruit mégantic après le désastre
on leur construit évidemment avec toutes
les normes à raccorder au réseau d'hydro
mais on ne construit un laboratoire avec
tous ces outils là pour voir comment on
est capable d'y noter une région et de
la langue des landes pendant quelques
temps sa mesure faut deux semaines sont
donc laissés au repos dix semaines alors
il ya beaucoup à faire chez hydro dans
la société civile chez les gens les
poteaux on touche pas aux poteaux de
bois mais c'est à dire que oui on est en
train de faire différente différentes
études bien différents modèles qui
peuvent qui peuvent se déployer
aujourd'hui le poteau de bois c'est
celui que le rapport technique coup que
le plus de sens bon les tarifs n'ont eu
les libéraux proposent un gel dans leur
plateforme qu'ils ont dévoilé en fin de
semaine un gel en attendent à leur tour
d'une éventuelle régis d'énergie
pourriez vous vivre avec un gel pendant
une année deux années passées pour en
fait la question c'est pas de ville avec
un gel pendant un an ou deux ans sophie
brochu c'est pas une bonne idée je les
tarifs puis je pense que tout le monde
le sait aujourd'hui ce qu'on a besoin
c'est d'accompagner des clients pendant
une période où il ya une pression
importante sur l'inflation qui en crée
un nouveau modus operandi ou aux cinq
ans on retourne à la région je les
retards if c'est à peu près la pire
chose qu'on peut faire pour accroître la
disparité des richesses au sein de nos
clients parce que parce que bouger et
arrive de quelqu'un que tous les sous
pour les pays à l'arrêt les bougies les
tarifs pour une personne pour certaines
personnes donc ce qu'il faut faire c'est
je pense que présentement ovine période
exceptionnelle et voit qu est-ce qui va
être conjoncturelles qu'est ce qui va
être structurelle dans l'inflation
présentement hydro québec fait preuve de
ce que j'appelle beau le supplément
d'âme ce dont on a besoin pour
accommoder nos clients un client qui
appelle aujourd'hui qui dit écoutez je
mal pris je pas capable de vivre ged
angoisse tout ça on prend entente dès
que quelqu'un nous appelle on suspend
toute interruption on suspend le courant
des intérêts et tout le truc tu es tout
ce qui existait dans le passé on suspend
tout ça puis on va voir quelle va être
la réponse légale donc c'est comme ça
c'est des cas
l'ine que vous gérez des jo avec plus
d'humanité mais pour des gens qui ont de
la misère à arriver le tous les jours
plus globalement cheval le cercle pas
mal plus grand que sonne oui absolument
mais leur relation jeanneton fait quoi
mais en fait il faut que les gens qui
encore une fois là je suis pas très de
minimiser l'ampleur de la pression
inflationniste sur les ménages je la
comprends que les tarifs d'électricité
au québec sont les plus faibles en
amérique l'orne on parle d'une
augmentation présentement de deux points
6 % sur le tarif le plus faible qui est
l'année prochaine le plafonné à 3 % au
moment où on se parle aux états unis et
à l'effet electric monte en flèche parce
qu'ils sont ancrés sur le prix du gaz
naturel qui fixe le prix est restée
parce qu'ils font ça présentement
hydro-québec fait beaucoup de sous avec
les exportations parce que le prix
l'électricité est fixée sur un prix de
l'énergie fossile qui aura en fait quand
on ne dit pas que quand on le compare ça
nous apaise mais il faut comprendre
qu'on est dans une dynamique où
l'augmentation le gel des tarifs et il
faut comprendre aussi ce qu'hydro québec
aujourd'hui l'assument l'inflation le on
l'appelle le transformateur la grille en
haut des poteaux ces 75 % d'augmentation
prix sur à peu près 18 mois viennent
devraient être commandés ma forme à leur
équipe et donc votre gestion le jeune
d'être juste pour être le gel des tarifs
ce serait une erreur oui puis jeudi
prochain dans les points des politiques
là je vous réponds comme une économiste
de l'énergie qui gère un service public
quand ce n'est pas politiquement neutre
et le par ailleurs d'avoir éliminé la
région parce que vous deviez aller
quémander vous vient à les faire la
preuve plaidé que j'ai besoin de temps
d'augmentation devant la régie c'est
compliqué puis l'arrêt j'arrivais avec
un chiffre lors c'est l'inflation plomb
plafonne à trois époques il n'y a pas un
côté sorcellerie à ça et que c'est pas
organiser puis avance était organisée en
fait vous dirai d'abord il ya encore 1
des voix la régie ou cinq ans aux cinq
ans puis on va prendre deux un temps à
faire un exercice de style économiste je
te laisse pas les bouches si on n'avait
pas eu les pressions inflationnistes
on n'aurait pas cette conversation
l'homme présentement je pense qu' on
dirait bien écouter on prend l'inflation
à un niveau 1 2% puis dans ces cas-là
régime elle va regarder les cinq
dernières années ont regardé la
structure de coûts d'hydro-québec à dire
est-ce que c'est cool on était
prudemment encourus ou pas en bon père
ou en bonne mère de famille est-ce
qu'ils sont justes et raisonnables en
fonction de poids jacques jeu j'impose
les tarifs excusable c'est parfait c'est
parfait puisque la glace est suffisant
vous je compteur et je redonne c'est ce
que je dis c'est que c'est un système
qui est efficient le présentement une
poche inflationnistes moi je dis donnons
nous avec le plafond qui est envisagé de
3% je pense qu'on est à l'intérieur des
débats des balises qui ont du sens
encore une fois avec un supplément d'âme
dans l'exécution de ce qui s'appelle des
ententes de paiement pour ceux qui ont
des difficultés évidentes en 2025 on
verra où est-ce qu'on est bien là la
société aura le loisir de revoir puis de
réfléchir à ce que c'est une bonne
affaire ou pas gravier là dessus si on
était dans le mode réglementaire le
soixante et dix millions il serait dans
les tarifs oui parce que vous dites tout
augmente et l'yonne en maintenant le 66
millions d'ha tempête la wii une tempête
dans un mode de règlement lorsqu'on fait
le sait que c'est le bénéfice
d'hydro-québec qui est un risque pour
tous parce que le 70 millions vous
l'aviez dit sur le terrain vous ne la
joue t pas non plus comme étant modéré
qu'on était en mode de loi 34
normalement j'ai renvoyé ce sont 10
millions - à québec exactement alors que
dans le mode réglementaire avant ces
coups-là aurait été amortis sur cinq en
état des lieux se fier au chum on va se
reparler plusieurs autres sujets merci
d'être venu nous voir on ne fait le
point sur la tempête et sur quelques des
sujets importants également merci à la
prochaine plaisir